G1
[Música]
eu era setembro de 2017 um fim de tarde
desses que a natureza abusa de se exibir
um pôr do sol lindo caindo aqueles sal
colorido eu tava lá dentro d'água
pegando uma onda perfeita atrás da outra
lá na Indonésia eu tava em Êxtase
pessoal era um dos momentos mais felizes
da minha vida tá então
e tava Claro para mim que o que eu tava
devendo era um presente eu fiquei com
uma vontade de fazer algo em troca foi
assim que surgiu a Esmeraldas lá dentro
da água desde então já foram cinco
toneladas de lixo retiradas as nossas
praias mais de duas mil participações
voluntárias 30 praias seis cidades dos
países
e 60 ações de limpeza de praia 60 vezes
Esmeralda e uma dessas ações me marcou
de um jeito muito especial e essa
história que eu quero contar aqui para
vocês hoje foi um divisor de águas entre
a Esmeralda de antes e as melhores de
agora eu era um deles que a gente tava
preparando para praia do Leme comecinho
da praia de Copacabana no Rio de Janeiro
numa noite anterior aquele dia eu recebi
uma ligação de um grupo de mulheres da
alta sociedade carioca que queriam
participar da ação com a gente elas
costumavam se reunir uma vez por mês
para fazer algo em prol da cidade e
dessa vez eu não seriam para Onda Verde
eu adorei a ligação Claro fiquei
orgulhoso inclusive e a gente combinou
de se encontrar no outro dia de manhã na
praia
acontece pessoal que amanheceu 40 graus
do Rio de Janeiro aquela manhã era alto
verão carioca lá na praia onde a gente
tinha montado a estrutura da Esmeralda
Do lado da pedra do Leme grandona tava
uns 200 graus Estava muito quente eu me
lembro das pessoas chegando e do
calçadão da praia até a areia onde eu
tava a maquiagem dela já tava toda de
retina as blusas abertas assim
esbaforidos as tava muito calor pela
primeira vez eu comecei a ver um
ambiente desfavorável para Esmeralda
para Onda Verde sendo formado ali isso
era o resto porque as pessoas estavam
sempre muito contente detalhe mas nesse
dia não Ela tava me perguntando coisas
do tipo vai demorar muito para começar
tem água para todo mundo tem alguma
sombra por aqui e não tinha não tinha
nenhuma sombra na praia do Leme aquele
dia aquela ali foi me consumindo e eu
tava perdendo o controle da situação
quando eu chamei meu time falei time me
ajudem ela conta de estudo aqui eu vou
subir ali na pedra tem um quiosque Zinho
ali na tela do Leme e vou subir ali para
pensar em alguma coisa diferente para
gente conseguir dar conta da segunda vez
que vai acontecer aqui hoje então subir
na pedra me lembro de ter olhado para
baixo e visto 150 pessoas de colete
Verde já antes que eu pudesse ter um
segundo sequer de reflexão venho
garantia desse tamanho aqui falar comigo
ela Júlio Júlio era morador do Cantagalo
na favela de próxima ele vem me afrontar
de alguma forma ele é assim que que
vocês vão fazer aqui na minha praia
eu falei sua praia ele é
vamos fazer uma limpeza de praia joguei
um colete na mão dele ele pegou assim do
SUS limpeza de praia não tô fora
devolveu para mim o colete eu peguei
efeito sabia Júlio eu sou o melhor do
mundo e nunca na história eu perdi numa
limpeza de praia nunca ninguém conseguiu
tirar mais lista aqui ó eu duvido você
conseguir
aí Ele olhou de novo pegou o colete
vestiu falou vão embora falei vou embora
desse com Julho antes de chegar na areia
meu fotógrafo do nosso time ele subiu
ali tira uma foto do Júlio uma prática
pagar um poema traz assim e hoje a foto
de capa do nosso site de cinco Julho
também todo mundo por uma roda fiz um
discurso super efusivo coloquei toda a
energia que eu consegui naquele discurso
ali e ainda no final de estou aqui com
juro numa disputa pessoal a gente vai
ver quem é que tira mais visto da praia
ou eu ou ele e começou a ação eu nunca
mais eu tô de nada Pessoal as pessoas
começaram a ação arrastando os pés pela
areia tava muito quente mesmo mas o
Júlio não o Júlio Correia aquela praia
50 vezes de cima a baixo falava com
todas as pessoas abordava todas as
barracas pegava latinha da mão das
pessoas e enchendo o saco de lixo
delicadas aquele cheiro olhava para mim
vibrava como se fosse gol do Brasil na
final da copa ele tava muito envolvido
ali eu sou sempre a primeira pessoa do
mutirão então eu vou dar o ritmo para as
outras e em um determinado momento eu
olhei para trás e vi a seguinte cena
Júlio correndo em cima baixa e Todas
aquelas outras pessoas correndo atrás do
Júlio para ajudar ele
E aí eu parei pensei por um segundo que
tava acontecendo uma coisa grande ali na
Onda Verde que conhece bem o Rio de
Janeiro sabe que é pouco provável que a
gente veja pessoas de distância sociais
tá manhas juntas ao mesmo tempo vestidas
da mesma forma com o mesmo objetivo sem
hierarquia entre elas ou melhor havia
alguma hierarquia do Julho as demais já
que elas estavam correndo atrás de
Gilson em 30 minutos de ação Não mais do
que isso a Esmeralda batia todos os
recordes a gente conseguiu tirar quase
400 quilos de lixo da praia do Leme
aquele dia vocês podem imaginar o que
são 400 kg de micro lixo e Toquinho
cigarro é literalmente uma montanha de
lixo E é claro no final da ação o juro
ganhou de mim de lavada a gente jogava
junto alto ele falava o dia mais feliz
da minha vida que eu só fez uma vaquinha
para julho com certeza ele lembra desse
dia até hoje assim como eu porque ele me
deu vários exemplos e várias lições ali
a primeira delas foi logo no final da
são eu me lembro de ter olhado para
aquele monte de lixo e ter pensado
seguinte mostra a gente tirou bastante
líquido aqui mas que praia suja
ele me disse logo na sequência nossa
praia tava suja mas quanto lixo a gente
tirou Vocês conseguem ver a diferença da
frase dele para mim é a frase dele é
muito mais otimista do que a minha
o que era esse o sentimento que as
pessoas estavam tendo a linha elas
estavam orgulhosas do que elas tinham
feito elas tinham tirado muito lixo num
dia muito quente e elas realmente
precisavam Tá orgulhosa naquele momento
entendi que a Esmeralda deixam de ser só
limpeza de praia e passou a ser uma
oportunidade que as pessoas têm de fazer
algo Nobre se sentir tão bem por isso a
ponto de entender em que fazer algo para
além de ser é fazer algo para si próprio
vou falar de novo essa frase porque esse
é o mais puro senso de vida em
comunidade acontecendo as pessoas
entenderam que fazer algo para o meio
para o próximo faz tão bem para elas
mesmas e fazer algo para além delas é
fazer algo para si próprio lindo isso né
a Ju também me disse o seguinte imagina
se a gente fizesse só que todos os dias
o problema do lixo no mundo é algo
inimaginável pessoal não consigo nem
falar aqui
mas a gente A parte disso a gente causou
a gente tem que resolver minha avó dizia
que quando a gente aponta
responsabilidade para alguém tem um dedo
apontado dessa pessoa e três à vontade
para nós faça um exercício aí imagina
Júlia se a gente fizesse isso todos os
dias e por último o Junior me mostrou a
força do exemplo mas o exemplo
verdadeiro ele vestiu a alma dele com
aquele colete Verde ali ele deu tudo que
ele poderia ter dado naquele dia o que
foi isso que fez com que aquelas pessoas
que começaram a ação arrastando os pés
corressem atrás do joelho e baterias em
todos os recordes da Esmeralda por
exemplo dele
um exemplo forte tem certeza que muitas
as pessoas que estão aqui tem algum
exemplo que carregam consigo algum
exemplo positivo ou negativo mas algo
que ficou marcado que ficou na gente e
que permeia todas as nossas reflexões as
nossas decisões
é isso fica nas pessoas assim como fica
o efeito de uma Onda Verde ela não dura
só aquela amanhã mas ela perdura e ao
ficar nas pessoas elas passam de umas
para as outras E é isso que me enche de
esperança é isso que faz tudo valer para
mim
e hoje olhando para toda essa trajetória
eu me lembro lá na Indonésia que eu não
tava lá dentro da água pensando que isso
tudo aqui era um sonho e hoje a
Esmeralda me prova dia após dia e nada é
tão real quanto o sonho
e dizem que a gente tem duas vidas né
duas é a Segunda começa justamente
quando a gente se dá conta que a vida é
uma só então Que tal levar uma vida não
abre com propósito deixar um legado
deixar um pouquinho da gente aqui quando
algum dia a gente for para algum outro
lugar se isso faz sentido para vocês
também sejam bem-vindos a família
Esmeralda a vida é muito curta para ser
pequena obrigado